Rich do you feel that the education
system is indoctrinating our children to
be more feminine
um you look at the pronouns
that are happening now people have their
pronouns I did an episode and I said
people who use pronouns suffer from a
mental illness
yeah there's a degree of mental illness
going on there and like pronouns are
just a star
you know you have these these kids and
that are encouraging kids to change
genders uh you know it's just absurd
when I was a kid if there was a guy
walking around
wearing women's clothing would be you
know you would you would point at them
and be like you know look at that with
their sort of thing that guy's a little
nuts
um you say that today and I had this
conversation with my kid back in the
summertime I pointed out somebody that
was a clear look you can't say that
that's not right that's not politically
correct and I had to take my time to
correct her and make it clear that uh no
that over there is mental illness and
parents the authority to parent them in
such a way that they feel is fair and
reasonable
um schools encourage the use of pronouns
school like
um there's a case I saw in the last
couple weeks there was a woman I think
it was in Florida that was being sued by
the state because she was asking
questions about what her child was being
taught in school
and imagine that you know you have a kid
in school and you can't ask what the
curriculum is you can't ask what the
school is teaching your kids I remember
when I was a kid when it came to things
like sex ed there had to be a consent
form that went home you know where your
parents would say yes it's totally fine
for my child to learn this correctly I
mean some parents would have their kids
opt out they wouldn't sit in the
classroom you know by their own choice
now schools are just basically saying
and doing whatever they want and you've
got schools that are lying to kids you
know they're using this critical race
Theory stuff they're using all these
Notions like they're feeding children
this idea that if you're white then
you're somehow privileged or you could
perhaps be racist or born racist you
know because of your skin color and that
just leans into areas of complete
absurdity it does it does and the other
thing that they're starting to teach out
there in society and I've really noticed
it in the past seven to ten years is the
whole toxic masculinity garbage right
that's being pushed Now Rich I don't
know what your opinion is on this
here here's my take on this there's no
such thing as toxic masculinity it's
masculinity and those who named it toxic
masculinity are feminists and beta men
and I think feminism is what ultimately
killed masculinity in in the western
world
yeah so that's interesting feminism went
through several waves you know it got to
equality you know let's be honest like
women
women have equality in the west they can
do everything a man can do you know
these Notions that women are paid 70 or
80 cents in a dollar for a man you know
for the same job a man would do is
complete [__] you know they've
they've turned that upside down men work
longer hours they work more dangerous
jobs that pay higher wages women you
know take jobs that are usually shorter
hours easier that don't pay you know
quite as much so that's been cast aside
but even though that's the case uh
feminism which I believe now and I start
using the term toxic feminism since they
like the term toxic masculinity let's
just play their game uh toxic feminism
is no longer about equality it's gone
past that now it's about a Supremacy
movement it's about the uh domination
and destruction of masculinity right
um the the subjugation of males to women
and it's not a good thing uh the funny
thing is is none of these women out
there that are that are straight that
are straight heterosexual women want
anything to do with the weak beta males
that they're trying to change men into
they only want to still be with the
strong alpha males
they do and if you don't agree with
their narrative they have another term
that they'd like to throw out which is
misogynist explain misogyny rich
women can't even explain misogyny like
if a woman uses the term misogyny and
then you say well can you explain what
that is like with a guy like Andrew Tate
you know he was the guy that was called
you know toxically masculine and he's a
misogynist and there's lots of Street
interviews out there of guys going up to
gals on college campuses and saying okay
well can you explain what a misogynist
then if a guy like Andrew Tate is a
misogynist and they couldn't they all
just walk away so they just use these
catchy phrases you know that they think
have meaning that will shut you down and
it's actually very easy to deal with
because all you have to do is just say
okay we'll explain what a misogynist is
to me and they can't they never can
right well rich and it's simple too I
wouldn't even waste my time in
conversation with somebody like that
um because obviously it's not a woman
that I'm going to be interested in or
attracted to if she's using the word
misogynist so it's a disqualifier
absolutely exactly I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out